Road to the White House coverage
continues today as Donald Trump holds a
rally in Green Bay Wisconsin the state
where polls over the last month are
indicating that he's trailing Hillary
Clinton by about five points will have
his rally live starting at 7:00 p.m.
Eastern here on c-span two NBA Hall of
Famer an author Kareem abdul-jabbar now
talks about his book writing's on the
wall searching for a new equality beyond
black and white it's here at the
National Press Club
[Music]
good afternoon and welcome to the
National Press Club my name is Thomas
burr I'm the Washington correspondent
for the Salt Lake Tribune and the 109th
president of the National Press Club our
guest today is the legendary NBA player
Kreme abdul-jabbar I would like to
welcome our public radio and c-span
audiences I don't want to remind you
that you can follow the action live on
twitter using the hashtag npc live
that's npc live now it's time to
introduce our head table guests and ask
that each of you stand briefly is your
name is announced please hold your
applause until I have finished
introducing the entire head table from
your rights Dell Quinton Wilber
Washington correspondent for the Los
Angeles Times who covers the Justice
Department West lower E national
reporter at the Washington Post
Margaret Richardson of global policy
development for air B&B Bruce Johnson
reporter an anchor at W USA TV John
Hughes editor for Bloomberg's
Newt Bloomberg News first word DC and
the 108th president of the National
Press Club Eric Holder the former
attorney general of the United States
skipping over our speaker for just a
moment
Allison Kojak health policy
correspondent for NPR NPR chairwoman of
the press club's board of governors and
the NPC speakers committee member who
organized today's luncheon Thank You
Allison Deborah Morales founder and
chief executive officer of economy LLC
the international consulting firm
representing our speaker and his
longtime manager Claire McNear staff
writer at the wringer Michael Fletcher
senior writer at ESPN's the undefeated
and Jamal Abdul Alim senior staff writer
for diverse issues and a higher
education thank you all
[Music]
it's not often at our podium we have
someone who is a major celebrity a star
athlete and an accomplished journalist
today we do creme abdul-jabbar is known
to most the world as one of the greatest
basketball players of all time
he led UCLA to three consecutive
championships and then burst into the
NBA in 1969 with his trademark skyhook
he dominated the league winning six
championships and being named an
all-star 19 of his twenty years as a
player and even though he hasn't played
in nearly 30 years at least
professionally he remains the NBA's
all-time leading scorer and that would
have been enough for us to invite him to
speak here today but it wasn't enough
for him since he left basketball
abdul-jabbar has become a best-selling
author of more than a dozen books the
range from a world war two history to a
graphic novel about Sherlock Holmes
brother Mycroft his latest work is
writing's on the wall searching for a
new quality beyond black and white he
writes regularly for The Washington Post
and Time magazine and recently wrote an
article praising San Francisco 49ers
quarterback Colin Kaepernick who
publicly protests violence against black
men by taking a knee at games during the
national anthem through his writing
abdul-jabbar who converted to Islam when
he was 24 years old has become a leading
thinker and activist for the rights of
African Americans and Muslims in the
United States and through his skyhook
foundation he's working to improve the
lives of low-income kids by bringing
educational opportunities into their
communities and if all this weren't
enough let's not forget that he will
also appeared in several films including
the 1980 comedy airplane abdul-jabbar
says he wants his new book to start a
dialogue about social and justices in
America and we hope this luncheon here
today will be part of that conversation
conversation ladies and gentlemen please
give a warm National Press Club welcome
to the tallest man ever to stand behind
this podium Kareem abdul-jabbar
good afternoon everyone and thank you
very much and thank you for that great
introduction I guess a lot of people are
curious you know why I brought this book
usually they expect me to write about
hoops or one of my other favorite
subjects that goes through my fevered
brain but I had to do this book because
it was it was very important to me
because of what I've seen going on in
our country and it's interesting that I
got it to chance to talk with my good
friend Eric Holder here about some of
these issues because it's something that
has affected our nation for such a long
time and we're just not at the point
where we can talk about these things and
trying to find a solution and that
that's really my motivation a solution
I have several suggestions in the book
about how we can deal with some of the
issues that I talk about I talk about
all types of things race aging a little
bit about Hoops and just how we've
gotten to a point where we can't speak
to each other and I've been inspired by
the founding fathers and the way that
they were able to come to a consensus
and figure out how to leave us with a
document that enabled us to have this
great nation that we have and we have to
keep this in mind because unless you can
listen with an open mind or express
yourself without bitterness you can't
have a communication you can't have that
dialogue and that's the one thing that
we need have too many people talking
past each other and giving in to all of
their emotional issues and the things
that drive them crazy but they don't
have the ability to listen to the other
side as to what their issues are and the
things that drive them crazy
so that's what my book is about I've
been getting a great response to it and
I'm very thankful for that because we
need to continue to do the work that
that that's been left to us dr. King dr.
Martin Luther King said that we had work
to do and he really defined it before he
left us you know we call all the issues
having to do with economic inequalities
and the denial of political and civil
rights to different segments of our
society well this has been a problem for
us since the origin of our republic but
we're just now getting to the point
where we can talk about it
so my book is here to encourage us to
start this conversation
you mentioned colin kaepernick i had a
chance to talk to him before he did
something really crazy and I think he
handled it the right way and he is now
as much of an inspiration as he was
annoying people with what they thought
was his disrespect for our country well
that's not how he feels he wants to make
our country a better place for the same
reasons that I do and he's gonna he's
going to get there he's gonna do what he
feels is necessary to get people to
start thinking about these things and
I'm really happy to see that the
movement is spreading throughout some of
the other professional sports leagues
the NFL definitely and the NBA is
getting in there if you saw the
assessment Awards LeBron and Dwayne Wade
and Carmelo Anthony and Chris Paul all
had something to say about the same
issues that Colin Kaepernick is talking
about and they're doing it in a way that
invites discussion and a reasonable
conversation as opposed to making people
angry and that that's what I wanted I'm
very happy to see that that that's how
it's worked out so
that's what you have in your hands if
you have copies of my book that that's
what you'll be reading about and I hope
you enjoy it I hope you get something
from it and I hope you can encourage
some of the people that you know that to
speak their mind on these subjects and
let's get to work on solving these
problems and I want to thank you all for
your attention
thank you sir let's continue that
conversation dr. Martin Luther King
spoke in this room in 1962 obviously
trying to you know work in the civil
rights movement of the federal
government's help it's been a long time
since then but we're still dealing with
a lot of racial issues how do we move
forward in this conversation how do we
do it is it is a neighbor to neighbor is
it encouraging you know events like this
how do we get this conversation going
well I think it absolutely has to be
neighbor to neighbor and for people in
in minority communities sometimes they
don't understand who their neighbors are
well one of the things that I'm hoping
for is that people in minority
communities instead of talking about the
police that they get to talk start
talking about our police when they can
do that that means that a bridge has
been built going from one side to the
other and when the police departments
and various law enforcement agencies get
to the point when instead of talking
about those people and they start
talking about the people that we serve
and protect then that that's another
another foothold for for a bridge and
those bridges can connect and III think
that that that's what we want to get to
where we get the people who need to be
talking to each other to start that
conversation so I think what you're
telling us if I understand it correctly
is we've got to stop the us-versus-them
mentality that appears out there and
following that question it helps to
understand and know somebody better
right so to start this conversation it
has to be a sit-down and I understand
what my friend here thinks and we both
can have that conversation together
right it's got to be about us it can't
be about my side and their side it's got
to be about us because we're all fellow
citizens you may have your own political
point of view but the people that you
see every day and in the communities
where you live they are your fellow
citizens and you have to have a means to
communicate with them to get to solve
problems so it starts with the first
conversation
when the problems are solved it's a good
question from the audience how do you
have an honest conversation about race
when everyone is afraid of saying
something wrong that'll make them look
like they're ignorant of some sort man
well I I think we can't be afraid of
being seen as ignorance because
ignorance is its what what's driving all
of this people are not dealing with the
facts they're dealing with stereotypes
Tamir rice is dead today because of the
stereotypes that the police officials in
Cleveland Ohio had about our young black
men is a 12 year old kid standing in the
park playing like 12 year old kids play
and he ends up dead because the cop just
got out of the car and he had heard that
there was a threatening black person in
the park so he shot the first person he
saw out there this is horrible and we
can't continue to have this these things
happening but the mindset that the
police install sometimes sometimes in
their officers really lends to this
problem perpetuating itself so the
police officials need to think about a
different way to train their officers so
that they don't overreact to innocent
circumstances so tragically following it
that question does it help to have
police in the community and not just
driving by in a car we used to know if
you cops used to walk the beat and get
to know their neighbors and understand
that does that help to actually have the
community police officers in the
communities knowing who they the
residents are there I think that that is
the essence of what we want to
eventually get to is that the police
officers know the people in the
communities that they police and
understand that they're people they are
not statistics they are not they are not
really Horton okay they are people who
have problems just like any other group
of people and police are there to
protect and serve these people and when
they understand their job in that
context a whole lot a whole lot of good
things get done you talked about call
protests during the playing of the
national anthem and that's extended now
to some other professional college and
even high school athletes is do you
believe this is a good thing and what do
you believe they should do to push for
more tangible solutions to the problems
they're drawing attention to well the
only way you can do that is to get
involved in the in the in a political
process I'm quoting President Obama
several times I've seen a mini and he
says don't get mad vote so we have to
participate we have to have people from
minority communities that are willing to
to run for public office and become
lawyers and district attorneys and
police officers or serve on a police
commission people from minority
communities have to have to be involved
that way if they can't be involved that
way bad things are going to continue to
happen when they are involved that way
their voice is heard and their community
gets the type of service that they
should get from the police department
question from the audience as well why
don't more athletes do what you did what
Colin Kaepernick did is is there too
much pressure to do not speak out too
much fear about not speaking out there's
a lot of fear for especially
professional athletes that they think
they're gonna ruin their brand and we
have the great and shining example of
Muhammad Ali who was willing to
sacrifice three of his primary years as
a world heavyweight champion because of
the fact that we were fighting an unjust
and illegal war in Vietnam and he had to
make a choice and he made the right
choice people didn't agree with him at
first but within a couple of years both
the American public and the Supreme
Court agreed with him and we did the
right thing with regard to Vietnam but
it took some some sacrifice and it took
somebody with the courage to stand up
and this is what we have to deal with
now the issues are that vital and our
country is sorely in need of people with
their type of courage and vision let's
follow on that just a second because you
dr. Muhammad Ali who lost his title and
probably millions of dollars in doing
what he did you yourself may have lost
some endorsements for speaking out
do you believe over time this has
changed become easier for athletes and
stars to speak out because there's less
of a price to pay well I don't know if
there's less of a price to pay but I
think the athletes are starting to see
that their value and what they can
achieve on the positive side is worth
the risk
so my good friend Michael Jordan has has
decided to to commit and he's given some
money to the n-double-a-cp Legal Defense
Fund and to some of the police
organizations in North Carolina and I
don't know if you remember several years
ago he he just wanted to be to opt out
of it saying that Republicans buy tennis
shoes also well they're still buying his
tennis shoes and he's able to involve
himself politically so it's it's not as
bad as it sounds you know you just have
to have the courage to make a stand
we've been talking a lot about
celebrities but let's talk a little bit
about ordinary people what does it take
to get some people like the
neighbor-to-neighbor conversations
you're talking about to get out of their
comfort zone and actually engage in
those conversations what can we do to
have them step out where they may not
feel comfortable jeez that that's I'm
the wrong person to ask that you know
because I don't have any choice you know
I feel that I have to do it but other
people they might have some issues
something that you have to discuss but
if you care about your community and
you're gonna be silent I think that
that's the coward's way out and like to
see more Americans with with the guts to
speak their minds and find out what
actually is going on and try to help
activate some some real remedies got a
lot of questions flowing up here for
let's go to the election first a few
minutes how does the Crim
I thought that was reaction I was gonna
get how is the current presidential
election affected race relations in the
United States and the ability of people
with different beliefs to understand
each other well I think the current
election has really pulled the SCAR off
of the racial divide in America mr.
Trump has said a number of things that
really are disappointing from an
American presidential candidate with
regard to race and the value of various
communities what he has to say about
Muslims and and people coming into our
country as immigrants he mentions
Mexicans but some of the things that he
has to say are just reprehensible and
have really course in the dialogue here
in our country I think it's really
unfortunate but that's who the
Republicans show so we have to deal with
that issue and we have to elect the
right person so I urge all of you to go
and vote your conscience I won't tell
you who to vote for but I hope you care
enough about our country to do the right
thing there's another question from the
audience
noting mr. Trump has his campaign has
brought out a lot of people speaking out
and ways maybe they didn't before and
the question is from the audiences how
do you engage with people who may hold
some bigoted or racist views well the
only way that you can engage with people
like that is to point out how some of
the policies that they are advocating
how they affect people how they affect
real people not in theory but in reality
I'm thinking of some all right let's
take to stop and frisk laws those really
have only served the purpose of making
the lives of people of minority people
in various communities miserable because
these people are stopped dozens of times
for no other reason than they live in a
high
I'm community and the police have made
it easier on themselves just to stop
anybody for for no good reason
probable cause really doesn't seem to
enter into their thought process and
that's wrong and there has to be a way
that policing does not have to involve
the cops just overstepping the
boundaries and just saying well you know
you live in this neighborhood you're a
person of color we have to check you out
that's that's not what the Constitution
says and it's illegal it's wrong and we
have to define a better way of policing
and to indulge in that have you ever
yourself had a personal experience with
police officers that you found troubling
oh yeah I used to drive on New Jersey
New Jersey Turnpike then I stopped got
my car to us a couple times did can you
tell us a little more about that is that
similar experience on a New Jersey
Turnpike yeah I didn't get arrested I
didn't they didn't write me a ticket
they just wanted to see what was in my
trunk I guess they thought I had a
cannon in there or something but it's it
happened to me a couple of times on the
New Jersey Turnpike let's go back to
election just a minute it's laid bare as
we just discussed a lot of racism and
religious bigotry there's been a lot of
commentary about that as a black man and
a Muslim how are you dealing with the
vitriol and what would you tell younger
men and women that are facing such
bigotry well I would tell anybody that's
dealing with that type of bigotry that
you have to confront it or you have to
take people that want to react to you in
a biased in a legal way you have to hold
them accountable and complain to the to
the correct authorities that you've been
discriminated against that's the only
way that people finally see the light
and understand them what they're doing
is wrong
and it takes courage I've been asked
this by a number of Muslims who are like
frustrated and statistics have said that
hate crimes against Muslim Americans
have increased at over 80 percent since
the Trump campaign started vilifying
Muslims to the degree that they have so
you know there's a problem there and we
have to deal with it but the Muslims
have to have the courage to stand up for
their own civil and political rights and
make sure that people who unjustly try
to vilify them are dealt with that's
that's the only way of dealing with it
back to mr. Trump he told even voters
recently what do you have to lose in
supporting him because he insists
governing Democrats are to blame for
failures and crime poverty and education
do you believe he's right in any form
have Democrats failed in at least part
all of sistex that that are available
say that violent crime is at its lowest
level in America in like the past 60
years and continuing to decrease so you
know what mr. Trump is trying to say is
is a fiction and when you realize that
it's a fiction you get an idea of what
motivates him so you know we have to go
on and react to the facts and not what
somebody wants people to believe because
he's running for office I don't think
that's gonna do our nation any good
since were on the Trump subject said
you've obviously spoken it even today
about his hateful words on immigrants
african-americans Muslims what's your
reaction and your take on the the issue
now with women saying they were
assaulted by mr. Trump well I just find
it odd that mr. Trump for years bragged
about assaulting women and now when
these women materialize and say yes you
did assault us he's calling them liers I
wonder who's telling the lie
I don't think it's the women with a long
set record of racism african-americans
were considered deplorable spiraling
politicians of various times in the
United States history Democrats in
modern times reached out to African
Americans to include them in the party
but what can Democrats now do to reach
out to a group of Americans Hillary
Clinton was labeled at one point the
deplorable
well you have to understand that even
though they might be doing or saying
things that are deplorable
they are your fellow citizens and they
have to be made aware of the pain that
they're causing for no good reason if
they have issues that need to be dealt
with they need to discuss them in a way
that enables all of the solutions that
are at hand to be applied to it and not
to engage in distortions and lies about
who and what is the problem
pulse of the country is more racially
polarized than it has been in a long
time but you have a black man in the
White House you have a black woman
serving as nation's top top law
enforcement officer in the military of a
black man is linked between the
president and the nuclear button
culturally black actors and music stars
are some of the most popular and
highest-paid celebrities on the planet
how do you reconcile the difference
between that the difference between one
did the fact we consider our country
very racially polarized and yet some of
the top elected leaders in the country
top serving officials are black and our
stars I think the the fact that so many
people of color have started to move up
the ladder into the middle class and in
some of them have become wealthy I think
that has alarmed certain people and made
them feel that something's wrong with
that picture but there's nothing wrong
with that picture that's just the
natural progression of people who
heretofore had not had the opportunity
to become educated and having access to
jobs and the powerful positions that
they're in
this is something new and a lot of
people are finding it hard to accept but
seems in our country seems to be doing
alright I don't think she's been any
problem there it's just uh there's uh
there was um I mentioned Michael Jordan
earlier there there was a TV commercial
that was used in that campaign and
Michael refused to become involved in
and it showed a person's hands handling
money and the person's hands there were
black hands and the whole idea of it was
that there was something wrong with the
picture that black hands were handling
the money nothing was said no no words
were mentioned about race but it was
very obvious that the fact that black
hands or or now at the controls that
that seemed to alarm people in North
Carolina and they voted according to
their fears so I think that just the
access that more people of color have to
better jobs and positions of power
really has created a problem for some
people who want to react in or in a
racist way this question of the question
from the audience
person remembers a time when there were
high number of murders in urban areas
were taken for granted didn't seem to
get as much attention that the lower
levels of urban crime get today do you
think that's a sign of progress I don't
know I'm pretty ignorant on that I don't
study police statistics that closely
unless I'm researching an article or
something let's talk about guns for just
a second there's a lot of talk about
people buying more guns in the last
several years more powerful weapons and
then there's the other side of that that
you talked about a little bit some
trigger happiness from some police
officers what can we do in this country
about the gun problem well I just think
that keeping guns out of the hands of
people who shouldn't have them you know
crazy people or people who are on
terrorist watch lists I think that is
has been pretty adequate it's the
loopholes that have allowed too many
guns to end up in our hands of wrong
people and we have to keep that I'm not
against the Second Amendment I just
think that we have to have a reasonable
means of monitoring who gets guns and
you know apply the adequate measures to
make sure that people who shouldn't have
guns don't get their hands on them
another question submitted today the
question of notes there are plenty of
minorities who are actually voting for
Trump and you're talking about bringing
people together and having a
conversation is a divisive for you to
talk about mr. Trump in the way he does
when there are minorities supporting him
no I I have to have to speak to the
truth that I see if they have a troop
that they see that supersedes this all
I'd like to hear about it but it doesn't
it doesn't bother me some people have a
different take on the reality around
them so it's not much you can do about
that except explain your take on reality
and see what makes sense well on that
note there are concerns out there about
reverse racism
the questioner notes there are plenty of
minorities who vilified white people do
you can you talk about the validity of
the concern about reverse racism in this
country I don't know where what they're
talking about reverse racism there are
very few people of color that have any
kind of power that would enable them to
that have a reverse racism program in a
victor ID on't know what they can do
doesn't seem to be reality to me all
right let's switch gears and talk about
you for a second you've made a very
successful transition from a spectacular
sports career to a successful post
sports life not all athletes have been
so successful at that was there
something specific in your personality
allows you to move on from sports to
reinvent your public self
well you know actually it happened
before I became a basketball player I
was into writing when I was in grade
school and it's something that I pursued
ever since that that time 1964 was the
year between my junior and senior year
in high school and I was involved in a
mentoring program that had a journalism
component to it and I got into
journalism at that point and I've
enjoyed it ever since then and it was
something that I always wanted to do
UCLA did not have a journalism
department but the English department
served my purpose is pretty well well
since we're here at the National Press
Club I appreciate that sentiment here
can you talk to us a little bit about
maybe a difficult time in your life and
what you did to persevere to overcome a
challenge you may have had well I think
just trying to figure out what to do
with with my life when I was at a point
there I was playing for the Milwaukee
Bucks and I had to make a professional
decision as to where I would continue my
career and I had to choose between
staying and Milwaukeean and moving on
and it was pretty easy after you know
you give it some serious thought and you
have to understand what's in your best
interests and my best interests lie in
moving to Los Angeles so I did that and
I haven't had any regrets about it well
that's the next question actually in all
of your life though do you have
something you regretted he would love to
do over again she's I should have stayed
with the piano lessons
there's a whole lot of people out there
that didn't want to take their piano
lessons I wanted I wanted to play
baseball that didn't work out but
basketball wound up so I ended up
playing basketball and had to give up
Brahms and Beethoven but it's okay
there's still time right no there's no
time
you mentioned this a little bit but talk
to us a little bit more about what
inspired you become a writer and and how
old are you when you got interested and
after your sports career why you picked
up the topic she picked up in writing
well I became interested in writing just
because in my household my dad was an
avid reader and more or less had to get
get with the program because he wasn't
going to talk to me I'd asked him a
question and he'd hand me a book come on
why don't you just answer finally I got
to the point where I could do the
research and I started going on my own
to reading all the things that
interested me and that was a very broad
array of things as all of you have kids
no it's amazing the things that they can
come up with that they wanna know about
right I must have presented quite a
problem to my dad but that's how it
started and I just kept learning about
things that interested me I started
writing about them and they have to try
them I know as a writer myself I faced
these but can you talk about some of the
challenges you faced in writing the
latest book and what surprised you about
the process of this book specifically
well I think that getting into the depth
and detail that you need to in order to
explain something really requires a lot
of research and I'm very fortunate to
work with my co-author or Raymond ops
vil he's he's incredible he makes my job
so much easier
but that's what it takes you have to be
able to understand all that you can
about any given subject and faithfully
deal with it in what you write and if
you can't do that what you write ends up
being shallow so I try to avoid that and
try to get to as much depth as I can and
explain the issues in a way that people
can see both sides of
subject and at that point we can have a
a discourse we can have a discussion and
that's a that's crucial all right and
this is actually a personal question how
do you get past writer's block because
we all face that sometimes too sometimes
it takes you have to take a day off a
lot of times it's just giving yourself a
rest and leaving the subject alone so
that you can come back to it with a
fresh vantage point sometimes that can
do it sometimes it doesn't but I think
most writers if they do their research
the way they should they usually get
over there there or whatever's blocking
them more
whatever's whatever issue is causing a
stumbling block they can usually get
past that I would like my editors to
take note the creme abdul-jabbar says I
can take tomorrow off
let me talk to you about this what are
some of the books that you've read in
your life that have had the greatest
impact on you oh okay
the souls of black folks WEP Du Bois
James Baldwin's essays the one with the
fire next time the autobiography of
malcolm x a tale of two cities to kill a
mockingbird nah those would be good it's
a good list you're also a fan of Sir
Arthur Conan Doyle and Sherlock Holmes
yes can you talk to us a little bit
about why you got involved in that and
out
you wrote the graphic novel I believe
well I used to watch the Sherlock Holmes
theater on television it was the
Sherlock Holmes movies that Basil
Rathbone made
and up until I had to read the
red-headed league in high school I
thought Sherlock Holmes was a real
person I didn't find out he was a
fictional character until I was a
sophomore in high school which is pretty
embarrassing but that's how it went down
and then when I started my professional
career someone gave me a complete
compilation of all of Arthur Conan Doyle
stories and that's the first time that I
read them it was my rookie year in the
NBA and of course we've travelled so
much I started reading crime fiction and
I graduated from Arthur Conan Doyle to
Raymond Chandler Dashiell Hammett Martin
Cruz Smith Robert B Parker Elmore
Leonard Walter Mosley other people like
that it just kept on going and I've just
enjoyed it it's great reading on the
road and some of the writings are really
profound I would recommend everybody
read some of Walter Mosley's novels
about the easy Rawlins his main
character in Private Eye it's it's
fascinating
it really speaks to a lot of the things
that happen in our country but from a
from a fictional standpoint but he makes
his points very very clearly I think
he's an incredible author and he's
really inspired me let me have some
other inspiration question who are the
people in your formative years that you
believe inspired you in my formerly as
well that's I would have to say Jackie
Robinson and dr. King Malcolm X Duke
Snider and this morning you I believe
you are at an event at the US Chamber of
Commerce or had some meetings there can
you talk to us more about why you're
with the US Chamber of Commerce today
why was that the US Chamber of Commerce
basically to just explain to some people
about business opportunities both here
in America and overseas I didn't know
the answer to that question before I
asked so it's good to go
another good question the audience do do
you believe NBA players play defense as
aggressively today as they did back when
you played or as scoring as high as it
is for some other reason NBA players
can't play as aggressively as they play
like in the era that I play because
they've changed the rules they kind of
dumb them down a little bit so you can't
be physical and play defense so it makes
it easier to score I think the fans have
enjoyed that but it was different
especially before the three-point shot
alright so this is a tough question some
of the audience wants to know are we
Americans yet in the word what are what
are the pillars that hold our support
what a definition of what Americans are
instead of being black white Muslim
whatever label we want to have are we
now Americans we are Americans when we
pledge allegiance to the United States
of America that makes us in America
I had the I had the pleasure of
introducing mr. Caan at the Democratic
convention and I was totally shocked at
his knowledge and embrace of Thomas
Jefferson it blew me away
and I think this is something our
Constitution is still the most dynamic
document that's ever been created and
it's something that we should be proud
of and use a lot more often in solving
our problems but mr. Khan understood
that and had no problem with the Sun
dying for our nation and it really made
me feel good to have a Muslim of his
character and knowledge to represent
American Muslims in the way that he did
and shut a lot of people up including
somebody that has a lot of blond hair I
dunno here Frankie
this is where the Press Club began where
do you get your news from is it online
TV do you subscribe to newspapers and
what do you prefer how do you ingest
your news as a consumer I get my
information from all the sources that
you just mentioned I read I've watched
TV and you know I just take it where I
find it maybe you could talk to spend a
little bit about Foreign Affairs I know
I just what's your take on how America
is doing in the world how America is
perceived in the world how America is
treating other countries jeez that's
hard for me to understand because I
don't spend enough time overseas and to
get a real you know finger on the pulse
of what you just asked me and that's
that's very difficult I wouldn't attempt
to do that I have no idea another
question the audience you apparently
passed and going to Israel several years
ago décima to to is called Israelis
treatment of Palestinians apartheid do
you think the US needs to stop arming
Israel and do you support the boycott
divestment sanctions
movement against Israel Malta by these
South African anti-apartheid I would
just say that the occupation stinks
that's the only thing that stinks over
the Rd Israeli state is a model of
democracy and transparency but III think
the occupation stinks it's got to end
well I hope it didn't soon
another question of Foreign Affairs do
you condemn the Saudi bombing of Yemen
should the u.s. cut off weapons going to
Saudi Arabia well I don't know enough
about that to have an inaccurate opinion
so I'm not going to answer that question
okay apparently the audience we have a
few fans of the movie airplane
the audience the questioner I said it
was the funniest sports cameo ever which
is a pretty nice tribute do you believe
there's any role in humor or comedy that
can add to the discussion of race in
America I think sometimes humor can
overcome certain obstacles because when
you're laughing your guard is down and
maybe that's a time when you can accept
some thoughts or a different point of
view that you heretofore were not going
to accept so I think humor is something
that that serves us well in that that
sense because when we lose our sense of
humor we lose a very important part of
our humanity and it makes it impossible
for us to communicate so what do you
think is more fun acting an airplane or
playing the NBA Finals she said I'd
rather be doing some acting something
you can do sitting downs
always better esra is there anything
forthcoming in the acting world for you
no basketball for a second if you could
assemble a starting five with players
from today or in the past we would they
be I wouldn't attempt to do that
might offend too many people it's
impossible how can you can't compare
people from different errors
you know how it shaquille have done
against will unless they go out there
and play the game
we won't know is there we have a chair
for you too if you'd like to sit down at
some deal there's a lot of standing here
we've only got about 15 minutes left but
try to get through a few more here is
there a single basketball game that
stands out in your mind or a favorite
basketball game during your time well I
I think the best college game I saw was
Princeton versus the University of
Michigan at the Holiday Festival in 1964
Bill Bradley scored 46 points I believe
in fouled out and Cathy Russell's team
was able to dominate at the end of the
game and win that game but that was
probably the best game that I had seen
the best college game I've ever seen and
I would you know as a spectator I put
that one out there there you go what you
see is the biggest barriers to higher
education for students who are from
low-income families and what obligation
if any does the government have or
provide pro athletes have or celebrities
have to help in this regard well I think
poverty is the biggest barrier because
poverty makes it impossible for poor
kids to have the time and resources to
become first-rate students they are
usually involved in a struggle just to
survive to keep a roof over their heads
in food in the pantry and they miss out
on getting the type of education at it
that opens up doors for them to ascend
into the into the middle class so I
think really you know poverty has a very
profound effect on how effective our
educational system can be and
talk to me for a minute about why and
and superstar athletes celebrities
should be involved what kind of
responsibility do they you believe they
have to get involved and what would the
benefits of getting involved to be oh I
can only speak for myself on that
subject I I can't say that what other
people should be doing I can only relate
to what I feel is correct and that's why
I pursue the things that I pursue but
there's no template that fits everybody
could another question the audience do
you believe that our country will ever
live up to its motto
e pluribus unum which is out of many one
well I think it is a worthy goal for us
to try to have citizenship for everyone
be the same it's a worthy goal we we
haven't gotten there it's it's very
difficult given the disparity in the
accumulation of wealth in various
communities but it's it's worth it's
worth trying for and the fact that
Americans of various stripes do have the
opportunity to make it all the way into
the top echelons of socio-economic
success I think is I think that really
validates what America is all about
I'm not sure the answer isn't yet either
but have you seen the new
african-american Museum of culture in
history no I would like to it's I've
read a number of the reviews on it and
it's supposed to be a very spectacular
place and a gentleman over there what
are you looking forward to most in going
over there to see what do you think that
would help the most for racial
discussions in America Susanna I
couldn't tell you that until I go over
there but hopefully it would show the
reality of the black experience in
America black Americans have contributed
so much to what American what makes
America great and we're not always
recognized for it so I hope that that's
what what
happening over there that Museum and
black Americans are given credit for
some of the incredible things that they
have done to contribute to American life
and now we're back to more basketball
questions because they keep coming in
who is the most difficult center you had
to play against during your career geez
that's not very many people gave me a
hard time there so I think the guys that
it was most difficult for me to guard
were people who could shoot the ball
well you know centers who could shoot
the ball well from you know 18 20 feet
because that brought me from where I
played my best defense so I you know I'd
say someone like Dan Issel
or somebody like that Dave Cowens Bob
McAdoo who could could hit jumpers from
20 feet that made my job a little bit
harder it's been a while since you were
a professional playing but what do you
think how is media and TV treatment of
the NBA changed since you played and I
extend that question to the players as
well how they how the media covers
players these days well I think the the
popularity of basketball has made it
impossible for the media that covers the
game to be vicious or you know
small-minded about what they're covering
because the game is so popular now so I
think I think they do a good job and I
think both the league and the media
people who cover the d-league or I think
they're doing a great job all right so
the question now is how strong was Wilt
invisible chairman how strong of a
competitor was he and no kind of
relationship did you have it oh I got to
meet will when I was in grade school and
he was like a hero to me
and then I ended up having to play
against him he was
a very imposing man physically weighed
over 300 pounds and was very powerful
and gifted athlete to give you some
example when wilt was in college he
played MC to a basketball but he also
was on the track team where he
participated in the shot put the high
jump and and the quarter mile that's a
pretty intense athletic regimen and he
was he was competitive in all of those
disciplines so he was a former athlete
and any accolades that you see about him
probably don't give him as much credit
as as he is due next question about how
can NBA players make the transition like
you did to a different type of career
what what's the key to your success and
what advice would you give somebody
who's leaving a professional sports team
to do something different well the key
to my success was the fact that I wanted
to go to college and when I got to
college I made sure that I got my degree
I prepared for life after basketball
before I got into the NBA
so NBA players who haven't done that
preparation I'm gonna have a problem but
some of them have and those are the ones
that usually are successful all right
question the audience how do you how do
you keep in shape personally is it
walking some daily exercise and what's
you know your regime do you talk about a
certain kind of food you avoid or use
diet I just try to get get enough sleep
a reasonable a reasonable amount of
exercise and not to eat the wrong things
and not to become a fat person and you
can do that
you might live a little bit longer we're
nearing the end here but let's let me
ask you since we're talking about the
issue still about your book what
is the kind of model you see for the
discussion of racial issues in this
country what's what's a good example
that you've seen or would like to see in
the country what I would like to see
would be I would like to see police
agencies reach out to community agencies
and vice versa and people living in a
certain community reaching out to the to
the police in that community and telling
them we need to talk we need to get to
know you and the police going along with
that program because that makes the most
sense I think well know when those
things start happening all this is going
to change we're getting down to it I'm
gonna ask the final question quick
before I do a couple quick reminders the
National Press Club is the world's
leading professional organization for
journalists and we fight for a free
press worldwide more information about
the club please visit our website at
presto RG that's presto RG I'll select
remind you about some upcoming programs
on Wednesday Secretary of Education John
B King will join us on November 21 Gina
McCarthy the administrator of the United
States Environmental Protection Agency
will speak from this podium on November
30th we host the general manager of the
Washington Metropolitan Area Transit
Authority Paul Whedon film under
December 2nd we had James Marin the CEO
and chairman of MGM and I know for
anyone who'd like to get their books
signed by mr. abdul-jabbar please exit
to my left your right and we'll be
signing books right out that way well
he'll be signing books I won't be
signing books lastly I'd like to present
before the last question our guest for
the traditional National Press Club mug
so my last question to you sir are you
uh do you still play basketball these
days and have you ever been offered to
play a game against President Barack
Obama or would you accept if he did oh
I've never been offered to play against
President Obama but I'd be happy to give
him some pointers that's great
everything else you'd like to add sir um
what was the first part of the question
do you still play bass I don't still
play no I I just try to stay in shape I
jump rope and lift weights sometimes and
sometimes I you know do various workouts
and some yoga just keep it simple
I try and staines one step ahead of the
Grim Reaper there and to clarify you
said you would coach President Obama if
you asked of course
that's great thank you very much for
being here sir thank you to journalism
staff
thank you ladies element again if you'd
like to have a book signed please exit
over here to your left to my left your
right
wrapping up here at the National Press
Club by the way all the National Press
Club luncheon speeches are available in
the c-span video library go to c-span
org well we have this from the hill
today the head of the FBI is pushing
back against allegations that police
have been gunning down black men and at
historic rates and weekend remarks at
the annual convention of the
International Association of Chiefs of
Police police FBI director James Comey
called for better statistics about
police encounters that leave people dead
and reiterated it his concern about the
so-called Ferguson effect making
officers jobs more difficult but we must
have a national database about our use
of deadly force he added with accurate
information we can all get better the
FBI by the way has launched a pilot
program to begin collecting the data
from police departments starting in 2017
you can read more too that that article
at the hill comm and donald trump will
be gathering with supporters this
evening in Green Bay Wisconsin state
polls in there in that state over the
last month they're showing that he's
trailing Hillary Clinton by about five
points and that's according to Real
Clear Politics c-span too will carry
that rally live it starts at 7:00 p.m.
Eastern coming up Tuesday President
Obama will host a state dinner likely to
be his last one for the italian prime
minister c-span's coverage includes
arrivals official photos and dinner
toasts and it starts live at 6:30
Eastern here's more Robyn Gavin
described Michelle Obama's style
our state dinner style yeah dinner salad
and apply that to the state dinners in
general well I think when mrs. Obama
dresses for these grand state occasions
the thing that really distinguishes her
sensibility from the bat of first ladies
who have come before her is that I feel
like it's much more rooted into a very
contemporary Hollywood idea of what is
glamorous and by that I mean you know
she's not wearing anything that's
particularly revealing or high slits or
anything like that
but there is a certain kind of modern
edge to it that really tops into what
we're used to seeing coming down a red
carpet it's less regal and more
glamorous has it changed over the past
eight years her approach to these state
dinners well I think her look has gotten
to be in some ways a little more relaxed
if that makes sense it was sort of
within that framework of glamour I think
when I think back to the very first
state dinner which was for India you
know the dress was gorgeous it was the
name Khan dress and her hair was up and
she had the bracelets the whole shebang
and she looked wonderful
but then I think to some of the later